quello che vi racconto oggi è una storia
d'amore è una storia d'amore come tutte
le storie d'amore che si rispettino a un
inizio un po complicato io mi sono
iscritto alla facoltà di ingegneria del
politecnico milano nel 2008 in quanto i
scrivino l'università di cio cambierò il
mondo distruggo tutto no lo distruggo
rifaccio spacco però il problema nel
2008 era che sei stato questa famosa
crisi no e giornale dopo giornale ma è
una crisi così mela la peggiore crisi
dal 45 tu pensi che sia solo in italia o
comunque che magari giornali italiani
esagero e poi vedi o no anche il wall
street journal sarà una cosa reale e
quello che le persone fanno quando c'è
un periodo diciamo di istituzione o
comunque quando si vuole staccare la
realtà sì ci si chiude gli occhi e si
cerca appunto qualcosa che ci faccia
pensare in un'altra maniera e nel 2008
la cosa migliore per distaccati dalla
realtà era l'iphone
perché un momento in cui l'iphone
spaventando nel mercato e l'iphone era
un nuovo mondo perché per la prima volta
avevo la mia tasca tutte le mappe di cui
avevo bisogno e tutte le mappe di colon
avevo bisogno e potevo anche postare su
facebook in qualsiasi momento in
qualsiasi posto in cui mi trovassi e
quindi cosa è successo all'epoca le api
erano completamente diversa da come sono
oggi per esempio c'era e book e blu che
aveva questa grafica che aveva questi
scaffali con le venature del legno di
colore del legno potevi sfogliare le
pagine del libro era qualcosa di magico
era qualcosa davvero speciale all'epoca
allora io in quel momento ho capito che
volevo essere partecipi di questa magia
volevo essere un designer mi ero
innamorato del design
però il tra il dire e il fare c'è di
mezzo il mare nel mio caso c'era
l'olanda o perché sono andati in olanda
e non era facile adattarsi in quel mondo
è andato più un più o meno così ho
dovuto intrisa armi e non è stato
abbastanza facile però fortunatamente
sono arrivato in questa startup che si
chiamava abse chi ha iniziato la mia
carriera di exane allora
la prima cosa che ho fatto ho chiamato
mio padre mia madre mamma papà sono gli
ex designer dopo 15 secondi di silenzio
allora ho pensato ma forse il problema
non è solo di amare il mio padre perché
secondo business insider interface the
sun è il lavoro più complicato da
spiegare i propri genitori in tutto il
mondo e non è solo lavoro più complicato
sui cari genitori è un lavoro complicato
da spiegare quindi ho pensato ma come è
possibile perché il design è qualcosa di
così naturale qualcosa dentro di noi
alla base della nostra evoluzione come
come esseri umani e nel mio caso
specifico
io lavoro con interfacce digitali e
l'interfaccia non è altro che un insieme
di finestre bottoni e testo che ti
permette di realizzare un certo scopo
nel caso di facebook per esempio è
postare sul suo ruolo oppure vedere
quello che i tuoi amici possono stanno
dicendo intuire giorno al mondo quindi
le interfacce non sono altro che
strumenti che noi utilizziamo per
plasmare e modificare il mondo che ci
circonda
quindi non è certo estende estensione il
martello è stato la prima forma di
interfaccia perché ci ha permesso di
interagire modificare tutto quello che
ci circondava
ma allora se è cosi naturale come mai il
design e il designer è così complicato
da spiegare beh io personalmente penso
che il problema deriva dal conta la dal
dualismo tra arte e design
allora l'arte per molto tempo è stata
patrimonio ad una cerchia ristretta di
persone di basti pensare nel
rinascimento quando la chiesa prega
mente era padrone non solo dell'arte
delle altissima della vita stessa degli
artisti e quindi l'arte è stata anche
nei tempi moderni era comunque
patrimonio d'una cerca di una cerchia
ristretta di intellettuali e
aristocratici bisogna aspettare il 1920
con volta il proprio scherzato il
fondatore da baus per dare un'idea di
cosa sia il design e cosa sia il design
ora secondo secondo glorious bisognava
creare un nuovo metodo di insegnamento
che poteva creare un nuovo tipo di
artista e questo tipo di artista era
qualcuno che era in grado di riconoscere
i problemi ma
li conosce i problemi umani non perché
fosse un genio o un prodigio di
conosceva i problemi umani e della
capace di rispondere a questi problemi
secondo un metodo preciso per la prima
volta abbiamo una definizione di cos'è
il design ma adesso ma allora come si fa
a realizzare questo perché il con certo
senso questo vuol dire per la prima
volta all'arte passava dall'essere
qualcosa di formale alle se qualcosa
utilitaristico quindi l'arte diventava
patrimonio della gente bisognava creare
per la gente la gente al centro
l'internet of the people
ma per fare questo bisogna spostare
l'oggetto della nostra della nostra
osservazione dal come al perché perché
il come eleva le nostre capacità
tecniche le nostre capacità artistiche
perché ci permette di capire quale
tecnica o vogliamo realizzare però con
il perché riusciamo ad arrivare allo
scopo delle cose e riusciamo a privare
la scuola riusciamo ad arrivare allo
scopo delle cose e riusciamo ad avere un
punto di vista
ora prima di lavorare per facebook che
lavorava ad open the ball opentable è
un'azienda che in america che si occupa
di restare servizio quindi puoi
prenotare un ristorante in qualsiasi
parte del mondo in qualsiasi in
qualsiasi orario è uno dei prodotti che
opentable oftware e gas center di e
center è questa applicazione che sia per
mobil che web che ti permette permette
ai ristoratori di vedere quante persone
stanno entrando nel ristorante se hanno
particolari richieste possono essere
allergie possono essere magari vogliono
un tavolo particolare e permette di
vedere dove queste persone saranno
sedute basato su un algoritmo che noi
abbiamo creato ora quando abbiamo
realizzato questo prodotto era
importante capire per chi stavamo
realizzando questo questo prodotto
quindi siamo dati nei ristoranti abbiamo
visto che le persone che utilizzano
questo punto maggiormente erano
camerieri e manager di ristoranti e
molte volte i ristoranti sono ambienti
bui perché mi novità della casa
l'atmosfera romantica e tutto il resto
giusto quindi quello che abbiamo fatto
noi quando creiamo il design vedevamo
come queste come quest'app si comportava
al buio proprio per capire proprio per
creare quel design credo che ci
permetteva di avere un design che non
affaticare gli occhi o comunque design
che fosse piacevole da usare anche in
ambienti poco illuminati
e quindi queste il mio amico tom che
stava provando un po quel design
quindi è molto importante la prima cosa
per creare prodotti che siano di
successo e prodotti che la gente
apprezza dell'empatia perché noi ci
siamo resi empatici dei problemi di
questi cameriere abbiamo cercato di
risolverli nella nella mani nel miglior
modo possibile è uno dei motivi
principali per cui abbiamo creato questo
tool era perché tutti i tool che i
ristoratori stavano all'epoca due anni
fa erano erano tutti di questo tipo è ed
è bruttissimo giusto è bruttissimo è
anche difficile da usare quindi così
come il perché è fondamentale però
bisogna anche non tralasciare il come
delle cose perché con il come riusciamo
a creare con il come arriviamo alla
bellezza e la bellezza è fondamentale
perché è stato dimostrato che le cose
belle che era una risposta positiva nel
cervello che a mente le nostre capacità
cognitive e ci permette di risolvere i
nostri problemi più in fretta quindi le
cose belle stimano la creatività è
quindi giusto per farvi rivedere un
attimo la comparazione questo è stato
dopo questo prima troppo quando la gente
usava questo prodotto ci volevano anni
c'erano agente che aveva 34 anni di
esperienza solo per capire come far
funzionare questo quando noi abbiamo
fatto questo dieci minuti la gente
sapeva come usare questa applicazione si
faceva esattamente le stesse cose che
faceva a quella quella quella vecchia
applicazione ora una delle cose belle
della bellezza e che noi come esseri
umani siamo portati a ricordare molto
più facilmente le esperienze belle di
quelle negative
e inoltre come se è stato anche
dimostrato che se abbiamo una buona
esperienza sul sito una persona è molto
molto probabilmente tornerà su quel sito
per per avere lo stesso tipo di
esperienza e questa una delle basi che
abbiamo utilizzato quando quando abbiamo
lavorato al re design di opentable e in
questo caso potete vedere come si appena
aperto il sito abbiamo queste immagini
di questa gente che sta cenando
pranzando insieme e questo crea quello
harris per la risposta emotiva e di dire
c'è la persona che vede questo sito
pensa quasi quasi
pregustando quel momento quando avrà
quella cena o quella o quella quella o
quel pranzo con con i propri amici è
un'altra delle cose molto interessanti
di questa immagine e che è stato
dimostrato che i volti hanno una
speciale c'è una parte speciale del
nostro cervello che è fatta per
riconoscere i volti non solo per
riconoscere i volti ma anche una
risposta o anche una risposta molto
positiva ai volti e questo è stato un
altro dei principi che abbiamo usato
quando abbiamo creato questa altra
feature che praticamente ti fa vedere
quali dei ristoranti dei vari ristoranti
quali amici
quale dei due amici hanno già prenotato
questo ristorante e questo è stato
dimostrato che ha avuto un impatto molto
positivo perché in questo modo le
persone erano capaci di vedere i quali
amici con gli amici erano riservate
ristorante e ha permesso di focalizzarsi
molto di più
prenotare questo ristorante anziché un
altro e questo è come il sito di
opentable era prima prima del design e
quindi una volta che abbiamo applicato
tutti questi concetti abbiamo avuto il
40 per cento in più di utilizzo del
nostro sito
in più la apple ci ha già nominato in
balia world e quindi sono un design che
è stato davvero molto positivo e adesso
voi direte
vabbè ma è facile per te riconoscere
cosa così è bello e cosa no perché lo
fai per lavoro
però io voglio sorprendere un pochettino
la bellezza è dentro ognuno di noi ci
sono degli ideali ci sono delle
proporzioni che sono universali che
permettono anche per me praticamente
accendono quelli del cervello ci fanno
sentire bene queste proporzioni vengono
addirittura è certo la stessa
proporzione che sono stati utilizzati
nel partenone
io sono stabilizzati nei quadri di
leonardo che sono state utilizzate nella
nella cappella sistina e quindi quello
che ho fatto oggi per voi ho creato
questo design di un blog fittizio e non
fatte due versioni una versione utilizza
quelle che sono le proporzioni e le
geometrie l'armonia umane e l'altra no
e io voglio per alzata di mano voglio
che voi mi dite secondo voi quale
utilizzi quale ma quale preferite
questa è la prima versione e questa è la
seconda faccio vi faccio di nuovo
prima lo so prima seconda per alzare in
mano quanti preferiscono la prima quanti
la seconda la prima è quella che
rispetta le proporzioni del corpo umano
e che il nostro cervello riconosce come
perfetta tra virgolette quindi la
bellezza è dentro è dentro ognuno di noi
adesso però come come possiamo
utilizzare questi principi per creare il
design del futuro
beh il futuro io spero che non sia spero
che non sia qualcosa di così perché se
c'è semini california è questo il futuro
ci sta il self isti che ci sta e lover
borsista spero che il futuro non sia
questo però quello che vogliamo fare nel
futuro cioè il futuro
la migliore interfaccia sarà l'assenza
di interfaccia quindi ci saranno una
serie di prodotti e servizi che ci
permetteranno di fare delle scelte senza
scegliere quello è il futuro del design
quindi è proprio e il limite
dell'empatia della bellezza perché non
c'è più non c'è più scelta è un falli
faccio un esempio io oggi 7 maggio sarei
dovuto essere a questa conferenza giusto
immaginiamo che crea un evento sul mio
calendario 7 maggio deve essere a torino
senza che io faccia nulla ci c'è questo
servizio che mi prenota il volo mi pare
nota l'hotel è tutto è prenotato in base
alle mie esperienze personali quale
compagnia aerea preferisco che tipo di
cibo preferisco se voglio viaggiare in
business voglio gene fisse casa perché
ci saranno questi servizi che hanno
acquisito talmente tanti dati su di noi
che ci permetteranno di fare delle
azioni che adesso sono tediose nella
maniera più semplice possibile quindi il
compito del designer sarà quello non più
di creare prodotti digitali o reali ma
sarà quello di confezionare queste
esperienze che devono essere quanto più
semplici possibili quindi il design non
farà altro che spezzettare tutti questi
vari passaggi e rendere la vita delle
persone più facili
ora in conclusione per poter cambiare il
mondo attorno a noi bisogna davvero
capito
quali sono le esigenze delle persone
cioè farsi responsabile essere empatici
capire cosa le persone vogliono henry
ford che il fondatore di ford motors è
famoso per aver detto quando leggi
quando gli chiedeva la gente cosa volete
la gente diceva voglio un cavallo più
veloce e questo perché come fa un
cavallo essere più veloce è giusto
quindi come come come come come invece
eri ha detto perché è un cavallo è
traccia l'automobile quindi ed è davvero
importante focalizzarsi sul perché delle
cose e capire quali sono i problemi
della gente
una delle una delle frasi cioè benigni
che adesso tante cose però una delle sue
frasi preferite
lui dice la bellezza è iniziata quando
noi mezzo da scegliere quindi io quello
che dovevo dire oggi e scegliete quello
che volete fare
fatelo nel modo più bello possibile
perché l'internet the people one altro
questo è bellezza empatia a ogni click
grazie